guys tickets for my special in Chicago
on December 2nd went on sale last week
and they sold out uh on the first day
because of you guys I am so grateful uh
that we are going to add another two
shows but that is it I'm not editing any
more than this but this is the huge
announcement right now they went on sale
on Friday
um we are going to do Friday December
1st as well tickets are on sale right
now at savocano comedy.com uh they are
on sale you don't even need a promo code
I am not adding more shows after this
the first two sold out immediately so if
you were waiting or thinking about
getting tickets it's Friday December 1st
those are on sale at sabalcano
comedy.com and I will say because I've
been being asked a lot
the contest still stands if you are
going to any of my tapings any of the
four tapings for my uh stand up comedy
special I'm going to choose one ticket
it doesn't matter where you sit and it
doesn't matter what taping you're at I'm
going to choose one person give you a
plus one I'm going to fly you to New
York put you up in a hotel and bring you
on a set of Impractical Jokers I want to
do that as a thank you to you guys
because I couldn't believe it sold out
so fast so you're still in it to win it
if you buy a ticket savocano comedy.com
right now Friday December 1st at the Vic
in Chicago if you have a friend that
lives in Chicago around that area let
them know again I'm going to pick one
person out of those tapings it doesn't
matter where you sit so grab those right
away the rest of the tour is also still
on sale with tons of dates
um as a matter of fact this coming
weekend I will be in uh
Bowling Green Kentucky uh Cincinnati
Ohio and Toledo and then we're moving on
to Wilkes-Barre Pennsylvania and
Wilmington Delaware in October we have
Macon Savannah and Athens Georgia and
even more and more dates all them up
right now on sale at Seattle County
comedy.com the Impractical Jokers cruise
is January 22nd to the 26th with Eric
Andre with Stevo and we're announcing
tons of more Comedians and bands this
coming week there's only a few cabins
left for that you can go get those at
get ship faced haha cruise.com that's
get shipfacecrews.com check out
nopresh.com
noprushnetwork.com merch and savvalcano
comedy.com for my merch I love you guys
thank you so much for your support I
really hope to see you on the road
also a non-traditional stand-up show I'm
doing right here in New York is on
November 9th at KGB bar as part of the
New York Comedy Festival I'm doing a
show called selected readings I'll be
reading excerpts from my recently
released audiobook The Penthouse papers
and I'll also be reading some other
stuff I've had published over the years
so come on out to that as far as
stand-up goes I Never Promised You a
Rose Garden is on tour November 11th
Philadelphia PA theater of the Living
Arts November 17th Pittsburgh PA bottle
rocket Social Hall November 18th Buffalo
New York the theater at Seneca one
November 30th Denver Colorado the summit
December 1st Phoenix Arizona Crescent
Ballroom and December 3rd Salt Lake City
Utah at the sound well there are more
dates coming soon but get your tickets
and show info and all that good stuff
for all the stuff I just talked about at
Joe derosa.com and of course if you're
in in New York City come on down to Joey
Rose's Joey Rose's nyc.com open seven
days a week
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
like two Fool's gonna fight but only one
food can be right taste buds man yeah
they're coming all right welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buzz
special day here we got a nice guest we
do and if there's one person that knows
about chance because we do chants on
this podcast if there's one person it is
my friend and Trio's Champion wrestler
as well as former tag team wrestling
Anthony Bowens of the acclaimed
everybody
I am so happy to have you dude I don't
think we've ever had a professional have
we had a professional wrestler on the
Pod ever no right yes number one I do
you are right and I'm such a I am such a
fan of wrestling so for me this is we
haven't right yeah I got the shirt on so
oh I got you I appreciate it this is uh
we're already starting off with some
issues I'm not gonna mess around I'm not
gonna not win shirt for my bar uh all
right that's self-promotion Alex
we made these to self-promercial you get
a belt on your mouth
I'll talk to the champ that way but
you're much Anthony you're much much
more uh not that I thought you were
gonna be like a dick or something but
like you're very gentle very gentle
uh approachable personality like I
thought I thought you'd be a little like
harder
or something you know what I mean like a
light switch thing because I can get
right into intimidating like a lot of
people say uh uh they're scared of me at
first because usually I walk around with
a very scouting a scowl on my face
because I truly I don't want to be
bothered but
um for the most part I'm just you know
one of the nicest people I've met I
swear to you oh thank you and that's you
could tell immediately you said it you
could tell immediately but you know I
would even even when I met you like
because I have plenty of friends and
even plenty of wrestler friends but you
just have just like just a really like
soft-spoken way about you that is so
approachable and uh yeah thank you go
can you go this would be a fun game yeah
this means happy this means gal let's go
I want to switch back and forth between
two ready okay all right so you're very
clear that you're happy yeah happy scalp
[Laughter]
do a split screen that shows my hand and
his face changing ready ready
[Laughter]
oh my God that's perfect listen to me uh
he is part of the Acclaim now everyone
just so you know I talked about people
like enchant they have they're so over
uh I mean I say this stuff as I walk
around my house by myself okay everybody
loves the Acclaim but you you want to
talk about somebody who could turn on a
dime like when you come when you get
into the ring and you start hyping up in
the beginning when you're just like
you what you do with your voice like I'd
be afraid are you ever afraid it's gonna
crack and then because he gets enraged
you know what I mean he's like they're
clean
and then he runs over and like it's just
and I'm always just like man I would be
nervous if that was mine because Max
gets to rap on the way in uh his
technique that's very cool and uh but
for me you have to get everybody like at
you have to launch everybody are you
ever nervous are you gonna just like
screw when your voice is gonna crack as
it ever happened it's never happened
usually my voice is shot depending on
how many shows I have right
um but I do have to kind of dig down
deep because this voice doesn't really
project well right right to a live
wrestling audience let you know let
alone uh so what do you do you you I
mean you you wow that's great what a
great finisher the the leap frog thing
you just did
anything uh it's called the famous or
yeah that thing oh I thought it said
finisher sure
that's great I would type in scissor me
Daddy ass so he can get a general idea
so yeah that I want to play the audio
because we might get in trouble for that
but correct because I think because it's
on YouTube so I think they like the
rights I think as long as you're not
because
okay so this is this this is your
signature thing that you do
this was National scissoring day
I'm dude I mean
so that's when it first started
[Laughter]
it's amazing
and then this is what I love about
everyone's scissoring in the crowd
they're scissoring that it just look at
it this is what I love about aew
dreams of being the fourth person that's
great
this is well never mind
I don't watch I
as much as anywhere near as much as I
used to but I was a huge uh wrestling
fan growing up I grew up with WWF I was
a WWF kid Hogan error all that stuff
when I was in college attitude error I
was huge into it uh
I fell out after that for you know
various reasons but what I love about
aew from what I've seen over the years
and whatever you guys really have
brought in my opinion the personality
back into wrestling you've bought and
that's not to knock anybody else but
it's just like you really have like that
whole scissor me Daddy like that's right
up there to me with like if you smell
and you know that's a big smell you know
if you smell but the pythons the the
Hogan you know uh you know whatever that
was called I'll take it I'll take that
like you know but yeah like all of that
stuff like that like that to me is is
you know the wrestling is obviously
wrestling but then the other component
to me is always the Charisma the mic
skills you know and that's arguably the
the more important part of the two I for
a while was trying to at 8 when we first
got signed like I want to have all these
crazy matches which I still do but then
once we linked up with Billy Gun Daddy
ass and he started
teaching us more the character-driven
things we don't really have to do as
much I can just punch somebody in the
face and just go
meanwhile before that I was you know
let's jump off the ladder let's go
through the tables let's do all this
crazy stuff which yeah it's fun but I I
enjoy not falling on my head as much you
know what's funny is I remember watching
uh uh
it might have still been WWF before they
changed the name but I remember watching
like Smackdown or something with my
uncle
and uh The Rock
was like uh you know got the most
electrifying move and he did the
people's elbow yeah and when he did it
my uncle goes because he didn't know who
he was he goes That's The Big Move
that's the most likely right and I was
ours might be you know a little worse or
better depending on your take on it we
have a move called scissor me timbers
okay where Max body slams the guy and he
holds up both of us or woman or a woman
so their legs are up in the air and then
I go to the second rope and I leg drop
their penis into a scissoring position
great
it's great
it's right up there I hope with the
people's elbows you're you're
significantly younger than us who did
you grow up on uh so I started watching
watching in 1997 so WCW Sting was like
the first thing I saw staying home wow
okay and then I uh started watching WWE
more and I watched I flipped back and
forth you know Monday Night War stuff
um and then just was a fan ever since
yeah well excuse me if you've had these
questions a billion times right but but
like what so now you are in the locker
room with sting what's that like like is
it just it's CR it's funny you ask that
because Max and I were looking at each
other maybe about a month ago because
sting came walking down the hallway and
he said hello and we're like this thing
just said hello to us and then he walked
back and he he didn't have to say this
he was like because we wrestled him two
years ago
um and on the main event of dynamite and
he said you know still to this day when
people bring up some of my favorite uh
feuds or programs that I've had uh since
coming to aew and we're right up there
with them so for a guy like me who you
know I idolized him he was the first
thing that got me into wrestling and I
was like that's that's that's really
cool that's so cool the um
do did I ever tell you my wrestling
character
no let's do it I did it at a dancing
Germain and Mike Lawrence used to do a
wrestling comedy show every year at the
creek and Cave when creaking cave was
still in New York and it was 35
comedians would have to come out and
each guy had to do a promo yeah and I
had I was like dude I have a character I
made up when I was in college and I was
like I'll do that character but my
wrestling character because I'm Egyptian
his name is King touch
I wonder where this is going
what are you touching
[Music]
the touch is based on give me give me
give me
he's a frail old man no the touch is
from uh biggie when remember when Biggie
say you know I'll reach out and touch
you meaning like I'll I'll smack you or
whatever you can get touched yeah so
that that's what the touch part meant
okay and then the two moves uh my two
closers were the pyramid drop and the
Nile pile
[Music]
and then you got to do it with your tag
team guy sure he's got to be another guy
so it's like a you know the way up here
we just keep conning people into losing
matches yes
but what was your what was your like
demeanor was your aura like what did you
do the voice like uh the voice was like
give me a good thing to say and I'll say
it in the voice
give me a thing to say
uh-huh come here I want to touch you
uh say say this Wednesday night at
dynamite oh if there's one thing that'll
happen you will get touched yeah the uh
okay yeah
because the king will touch you like
that that was the voice
[Music]
gonna talk
it was one of the voices I would do in
uh remember when Prince Paul was here
yeah and I gave him the CD and like oh
man old rapper one of the characters in
there that was named Bernard Valentine
and and and that was the voice basically
I'm a little rusty on it but that was
the voice like a higher register yeah it
was like it was like an old school rap
you know where I came with that voice
when I first started doing comedy I had
a joke about old school rappers okay and
I'll go
like that and do because that's what
they all sounded like not all everybody
but yeah it was like you know yeah how
about so I could own down you know what
I mean like that you know I don't I
don't see this I don't see that as a
wrestler I also don't see it as a king
touch it's my wrestler you came out it
sounded like a it sounded like a um it
sounded like a a southern
frog and it just doesn't go away it's a
good manager the Egyptian king it's a
good manager voice let me tell you
something to eat W fans oh okay you guys
come out here and touch some people
tonight it's a gun manager that now I'll
give you a little mouth to the South
there yeah exactly Jimmy heart yeah I
can hear that yeah
[Music]
isn't Egyptian though so no no but this
is It's diversity hires okay sure sure
we're inclusive at aew clearly
you never came up with a you're a huge
resume you never fantasize and like made
up a restaurant I was on the Jericho um
Cruise
um what's the Jericho crew I mean I know
what it is but what he does a rock and
wrestling I had done we had done a
cruise for a few years then he was going
to have one we were buddies with him and
uh he he had booked up and we're like oh
we want to come on he's like just come
on so he went on me and Q did what say
you are a podcast okay and uh or defunct
podcast but we went on and we did a show
they we were in the ring for the show
which is awesome and the whole show was
like basically we were comparing we made
up characters for me and that's the only
time I did it but yeah I might have I
might have some in here did I tell you
this by the way we're at the San Gennaro
festival yesterday I was telling you
earlier
I'm there with my partner Paul Italia
who I own my Joey his last name's
Italian that's perfect for this
engineering he's the guy I own my
sandwich shop with anyway
so I can't believe I forgot to tell you
this we're standing eating fried clams
at the Umberto stand this lady comes up
to us she goes excuse me I'm so sorry
are you two the famous pranksters
and I go what she goes when I practice
she goes are you two the famous you're
the famous practices and I'm like so I
guess she recognized me from a taste
clip thought he was you and then the
taste buds was somehow part of
Impractical Jokers I just like no Miss
that's not us and she was like but I
know you
they have a filter oh you have to
scissor people on the streets and stuff
yeses are people everywhere legitimately
yeah
um it was there's no not doing it you
must carry antibiotics scissors or oh
yes I always have hand sanitizens that's
actually a story
um I was taking and I will be blunt a
massive and I went to go and I went
to go wash my hands and before I can get
to the sink someone walked in no and was
like oh my God poets oh my God can you
scissor me and without bathroom in the
bathroom and without thinking I just
went and I scissored them it's the hand
I wipe with
so I call that the dirty scissors wow
but yeah we do it everywhere it's
totally his fault don't approach a man
in the bathroom like yeah that's wild
yeah it's everywhere when you do the the
scissor thing on the street
you don't have to go you just you just
do it like I give a little like a
motorboat oh you will do a little taste
of what I actually do right yes I guess
I guess that's what that because it is
funny the Casual scissoring is very
funny like I'll talk to you tomorrow
baby thanks you know what I mean
yeah
dude watch casual big fan bro oh yeah it
is
[Laughter]
I love his I have in my head right now
you getting pulled over by a cop and
you're and the window's down he walks
over he recognizes you and you think you
think he might recognize you and I
picture you going like this like
that slightly happened two days ago not
I didn't get pulled over but I was
walking by a police station to go to a
show and the cop stopped me and he was
like I got a scissor you man
it's like okay but for people that don't
know how do they come about yeah that's
I I wanted to know that as well so uh my
partner Max caster and I we are the
acclaimed or attack you guys are both
East Coast guys East Coast I'm from New
Jersey he's from Long Island yeah
um we both trained under the same school
Creator Pro New Jersey he was in Long
Island I was in New Jersey and um we got
signed together at aew the owner Tony
Khan uh made us a tag team called the
acclaimed and he he raps I'm his hype
man and we're always just trying to find
little things that were fun to do Castor
loves just taking things the extra mile
and playing jokes on me in the ring so
one day I threw up my my fingers like an
a for the acclaimed and he came from
behind me and he scissored my fingers
and it's on camera I go
because I'm very I was very reserved I
kind of tapped too much into my like my
normal self sure and Max is always like
balls to the wall yeah
um we did a couple more times they were
like I don't know if the network wants
you guys like doing that so maybe hold
off and then at some point we were just
like this we're gonna just we gotta
do something yeah so we started doing it
again and then I noticed
um when I was laying on the ground the
front row had their fingers out they're
like bow and scissor me come on and I
went huh we got something so I started
leaning into it on the entrance I added
the motor boat thing yeah
um I added the we'll throw our fingers
up and we'll go corner to corner and The
Crowd Goes
and then Billy gone capped it off with
the daddy yes daddy yes and then the I
mean you guys had to be like top merch I
mean it's like yeah for over half a year
were the top merch sellers they they
fought us on that shirt too I every week
was like make the shirt make the shirt
make the shirt Tony then wanted it and
then it became number one shirt in like
a day or two yeah I loved by the way
that you're working excuse me that you
work with Billy Gunn
because New Age Outlaws
good so good we're my favorite tag team
ever like I I oh really when they came
out ladies and gentlemen children are
the road dog Jesse like the badass Billy
I used to love I used to get so excited
oh you didn't know
I would get you know revved up at that I
just got chills saying it I think you
underplayed his wrestling knowledge well
I knew you hadn't watched recently I've
just been out of it so what happened was
when the attitude error and touch had
his day
error ended YouTube King touching this
day and age he's so funny I just
immediately need to it's just like he
just comes out like I'm King Tut and now
the Music Stops like that
but when the attitude error ended it was
it was coincidentally right around the
time I was getting out of college okay
and so so this era that I loved so much
that brought me back into it ended and
there was a major shift in wrestling
just personality wise
and it was also when I got out of
college I moved not just away from home
but I moved to Austin Texas so
just everything traditionally for me
that that had gotten me back into
wrestling and what it was and like
watching it with these certain friends
in this certain region of the country
and all that stuff it all went away at
once and then the next thing you know
it's like five years later and you're
like I haven't watched in a while like
oh John Cena oh yeah okay you know like
and that was it I just kind of never I
just kind of never slid back in and then
this thing that started to interest me
again
forgive me if I'm mistaken but Kurt
Angle was one of the earlier guys that
went over to aew if I'm not not anymore
TNA you're probably thinking of Cody
Rhodes
Chris Jericho who did
TNA it was TNA sure
so TNA when I remember when he went to
that other league that was when I
started I was like oh that's cool
there's like this new league or whatever
and then later I heard about aw and I've
I've tuned in here and there and watched
clip but like I truly mean what I say
like the thing I think and I've said it
to you before what I like about what you
guys are doing and I should start
watching but wrestling is like comic
books man sure you know you're like how
many issues in are we you know what I
mean I gotta jump in I mean yeah I think
you could pick up at any time depending
on whatever those storylines are that
time that's all and then you get a
little back you know for me dude I I I
end up getting SummerSlam tickets like
seven years ago from somebody and I
hadn't gone I didn't I stopped watching
as a kid I the attitude I only watched
peripherally my friends had we had a
beach house and they all watched it and
I so I only saw peripherally and then
when I went to that live event I was
like immediately hooked again and then
and then when when the aw launched it
was unbelievable because we're also on
the scene that's kind of the similar
story yeah to me because I fell out a
little bit and probably 2005 I watched
Loosely but like everybody in high
school it's like oh that's not cool
anymore I secretly still loved it but I
didn't watch as much and then I went to
SummerSlam 07 at um Izod okay and I was
like huh this is funny yeah and I got a
buddy casual fan they'd be like I'll do
that yeah I gotta start where I have
buddies that you know Cole caban is a
buddy of mine cool and uh and Dylan
postal now you know uh so like
Hornswoggle yeah I gotta I guess you
gotta get both buddies yeah shout out to
both guys I gotta start watching again
dude is it rude I have to pee so bad and
I'm I don't want to stop for a second
okay I just I'll be really fast yeah
what's up guys let's talk about game
time game time is an app I use and you
should too to get last minute tickets at
the best prices
guaranteed uh they're all in prices you
get the views from your seat on the app
so you know exactly what it's going to
look like they have a best price
guarantee uh where in ass you will
always get the Press price if you find
tickets in the same sectional Row for
Less game time we'll credit you 110 of
the difference
um these are tickets to everything there
are tickets to concerts and sports and
musicals and comedy uh everything is on
there okay I personally don't like uh
buying tickets ahead of time anymore you
never know what's going to happen that
being said if you're coming to see me
buy your tickets immediately don't wait
till the end or if you do wait till then
you use game time take the guesswork out
of buying tickets with Game Time
download the game time out today create
an account use the code taste buds for
twenty dollars off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem the code uh taste buds
t-a-a-s-t-e-b-u-d-s for twenty dollars
off download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed guys
let's talk about prize picks what is
prize picks prize picks is the largest
independently owned daily fantasy sports
platform in North America their easiest
and the most exciting way to play daily
fantasy sports it's just you against
numbers that's all it is so instead of
battling thousands of other players
including pros and sharks you pick more
than or less than on a two to six player
stat projection and watch the winnings
roll in some examples
you have quick withdrawals easy gameplay
and an enormous selection of players and
Stat types are what makes price picks
the number one daily fantasy sports app
this week on the prize picks um
basically for example
I'm just picking with players right so
after the I don't know I mean after the
drubbing that the Giants took last week
I feel they're on a bounce back so I'm
gonna take saquon for more than 60 yards
and even Mahomes I think if Kelsey's
playing this week uh I'm gonna go more
than two passing touchdowns on my homes
and that's it that's as easy as it gets
um
so go to prizepix.com tastebuds and use
the code taste buds for a first deposit
match up to 100 okay again go to prize
picks.com slash taste buds and use code
taste buds for a first deposit matchup
up to one hundred dollars uh daily
fantasy sports Made Easy that is prize
picks and again guys if you are a little
bit like you don't like drafting full
teams or betting games against each
other this is totally different way to
play and you could root for one player
it's a lot of fun uh if you're into
football uh I would say check it out
before we even jump to the wrestling can
can can you pass can I can I hold that
belt can I see that the scissor title
yeah the trio sure this is the
feel the weight on this thing feel the
weight on that
were you expect it to be to be that
heavy
that's great so do you know how who like
how how long does this take to get to
you how when did you find out because
they're not always customized correct no
so we are so this is luckily we are
popular and when I request the first
time I've seen a a belt like this is a
another level of customization like I
love the pink and then but to have this
Scissor on the end dude it's so funny
that they were pushing I don't want to
disrespect this but is it okay if I put
it over my God no it's not disrespectful
I don't know how like Precious you're
all and I don't I'm the champ now
the dream I'll never achieve like I'm
the I'm you know because someone like
him is like oh I like wrestling I'll
become a wrestler like I
I mean you were an athlete obviously
baseball you're baseball athlete oh
really would you what position that was
an outfielder
um center field in high school and then
two years at Seton Hall University oh in
the Big East I was in left field and
then I transferred to Montclair State
and I was at right field that's crazy so
and then you were just like you went to
you went to summerslamo seven and you
were like I'm not gonna play baseball
and I'm gonna rest well no I played
through college and I wanted to play pro
ball but I was uh
terrible tendonitis in my elbow and I
kind of fell out of the Love of the Game
because playing for that at least for
the guy at Montclair State he was just
miserable to play for it I just didn't
want to do it anymore yeah so when I
stopped playing I was trying to figure
out something that was like athletic and
creative to do it went from one really
intense thing to the next yep did you
going into it obviously there's no
promises on anything right so the
intensity how how long is it how how
intense and how long is it
um when you're training and you're
you're like hoping to get like what is
it try out or is it like they come watch
like so I I got you can train a train
you can join a wrestling school right
there's wrestling schools all over the
place specifically I ran remember
Santino Marella yeah it does yeah I ran
into him at the gym and he gave me the
number to Pat Buck to who's the owner he
actually is an agent at ew now which is
cool like he does my matches
um but he's the owner and trainer at
Creator Pro
um in Rahway New Jersey and I started
training with him the next week and then
eight took me eight years to get signed
I think eight years on the independence
and this is living your life and then
grinding everything you have
yep at the school at the school not even
knowing if you're going to get to a
level that you're happy with or that
you'll become a professional wrestler
yep so what's what's it like the day
that you get that call like what how
does that have that take us through that
so for me it was a little I was lucky
because I had the option of choosing
between WWE or aew
um I had they had WWE had said they were
going to sign me back in 2017 and then
nothing just happened I never heard from
him again and then I worked for aew
during the pandemic as a connection or
they gave me a match and then
legitimately the next day they were WWE
reached out was like oh are you a free
agent and then they offered me a
contract I said yes and then I didn't
know that yeah I I committed to NXT they
never sent me a contract and Tony Khan
found out about it and since I didn't
hear anything for a second time and
there was a bunch of other stuff going
on but he flew me down to Jacksonville
where I met Castor who was going through
something similar and we did a tryout
match for him and I came back through
the curtain and I saw him give a thumbs
up and he offered us contracts and I
said this is where I want to be holy
that's great what's your feeling in that
moment it's like I was late I cried my
yeah I uh when I first got the original
phone calls with my family and Michael
my boyfriend and uh it was it was just
great I can't even imagine dude I can't
even such a relief and then and then
when you first won these yeah we won the
tag titles in the last year in New York
City at Arthur Ashe Stadium for the
first time and it was just I just got
chills it was so cool I watched so cool
that's I'm so happy for you man I
couldn't it couldn't happen to a nicer
person well thank you yeah that's great
that's great I can have this then or uh
well they're selling those replicas 45
000. you know what else they're not
replicas excuse me people yelled at us
all weekend because of these the price
point they're legitimate belts handmade
from the uh from the person himself who
created them red leather belts so people
didn't get this belt fans can get 10
made in existence replica belts take
about eight months to get produced so
that will be down the line but like the
legitimate like if I lost that they
would make a new one for me that's the
one you'd be purchasing no way yes and
oh so when are they on sale already
they're on sale there are six left how
much do they cost five thousand dollars
they cost four to be made wow
actually did I show you the original
sketch I made for that you ensure this
thing no oh you
you I
well he'll just kill somebody
I mean Jesus man
I'm nervous I'm carrying my computer
around I get nervous like this is like
crazy
tell me if you feel a difference I just
remembered I'm also friends with Tyrus
another wrestler though I'm friendly
with throw that around and guess like
how does that make you feel
it's heavy right right I know I didn't
mean literally I just felt like doesn't
that do something for you
no no Own It Like It's Your make believe
it's yours what I'm saying hold put your
hand on it feel it I understand make
believe you're a champion for once in
your goddamn life
it feels secure
you don't feel like a a boost in your
confidence with that over your shoulder
no really
good I got a little bit of such a
miserable answer you sounded like
Squidward the magic conch like now
I felt like a little bit of like a go
get them when I threw that on I felt
like let's go like who's next
it's added weight to my mom
I don't feel that I can move quickly
he's like cumbersome oh wait wait so I'm
not going to tell you what activity I
was doing uh before I drew this okay
um but I was sitting there thinking
about it and I drew the sketch up and I
legitimately sent this into the office
[Laughter]
you can show it to the camera can we
I'll send it can you text anymore that
and that became this it's
like literally it's it's hysterical but
I don't know if I would have sent that
it is yet you wanted a smiley face as
the middle no I like I was hoping
so they had a nice you know day I just
forgave my friendly smile
like that like yeah
what they hadn't working scissor itself
and we can scissor each other the uh
that's that's really interesting that's
what I was gonna say your parents saw
that and then I'm gonna put this down
now uh yes that's fine we should do uh
before the battle though one thing I
want to say that I also love about what
you're doing
is uh with the scissor thing
it's the it's the perfect level of
immaturity that wrestling has when it's
at its best yep yes it's wrestling at
its best is a little immature sometimes
it's a little insulting but in a funny
way you know absolutely and like that's
just that's what I always
you know like you know like the rock
poontang pie like it's like that kind of
thing I just I love it so I have a
question so you you touched on this
earlier about like you're not sure if
they're going to want you to do that
because you know when it
is the is it still Veil like when you
say it as according to aw and and the
fan like when when you guys do that it's
just your own you co-opted this thing
and it's basically like giving each
other a fist pound kind of way it's it's
but it hearkens to something else sure
so like how have you gotten any pushback
at all in any capacity whatsoever like
advertisers or like or just from Tony or
whatever like once they were on board I
mean once everyone's doing it
I mean because you said they pushed back
on the shirt even right I think it was
more the network pushed back on it no
not to get in trouble we love you
network
um TBS and TNT uh we're in the same
family oh yes yes true TV yeah um but
yeah originally they pushed back and
then we got it and they saw the success
of it and then they started making
commercials about it to to uh you know
hype up dynamite every week
like we told you if you would have did
it from the beginning right you know
we'd had a little bit more of it but
they they're all about it now they
really are all right I'm gonna hit you
just with a couple of my rest
just just Top Line and then we're gonna
move right into the battle okay all
right I don't remember these I'm not
saying they're good
um
I one one guy was worked for the TSA one
wrestler and his moves with a full body
cavity search uh and the pre-check and
that person was always in a state of
snark
the naming the names the whole thing I
can sit here all day and give you
personalities give me a again like the
rest of these the deadbeat dad his moves
the alimony check yeah and the Daddy's
home
um let me see
hold on uh
like drunk dad would be good he takes
his belt off to beat you with it
you know okay all right
yeah
papa bear T you name the wrestler Papa
Bear's a good name for a wrestler the
hoarder
and uh basically uh he he bought a
championship not a yard sale and can't
let it go I don't know what they said
these are bad these are terrible Devin
from the Devon from the corner I loved
it Devin from the corner is in meth head
who people are afraid to touch lest they
contract hepatitis so it varies on the
ailments he wins by count out undefeated
[Laughter]
uh triple tag a trio
they don't mention cereal of puns but
okay a demon child whose half brother
killed and burned their family and was
left physically and emotionally damaged
comes back to avenge their family's
mirror and settle the score is his only
reason for existing then when that Feud
ends you stick around for 20 years and
just become a wrestler that's already a
Restless
it's like Kane that was the joke
uh uh so pick a name all right how many
needs to be doing here all right
just give me an idea of where the finish
line is on this list Joe the lunar
driver no no give me an idea of where
the I'll say one more okay the uh Joe
the Uber driver I'll name him Joe he
shows up late to the match and he goes
past the ring
and he thinks he knows the best way that
the match should go
I gave you a true idea for a wrestler
okay we're working bits here gluten
these are these are you didn't
think these were good ideas I think
they're fantastic to be honest with you
someone in the industry babe because you
guys are friends he's got to say that
you're on the same Network promos
today
you gave us a list of things that he
liked from foods to rest of this that
the other and one that stuck stuck out
well it was he said IHOP right and we
said I said I like IHOP versus Denny's
and we're kind of going back and forth
on that and then
Anthony you said
well you know I really like Waffle House
too and I said I hate Waffle House and
you immediately were like what yeah and
I was like okay it's got to be Waffle
House versus Denny's and I think because
these are the two these are the these
are the two places you go when you have
very limited or or or or in a rush
breakfast options or you were very late
at night exactly yeah and also both no
strangers to controversy Waffle House is
a fight every other week gets on to you
know uh World Star Hip-Hop or whatever
is its own Federation yeah sure we can
put that on TV right away Jeff
so lots of fights are worth and then
Denny's has gotten into some some social
issues see I'm not too
so you're gonna have to explain it
I remember exactly what it was but
Denny's got in trouble there was
something racial with Denny's where
Denny's was like racist for a minute
like where really Denny's agreed today
to pay more than 54 million followed by
thousands of Black customers who had
been refused service I'm not laughing at
the racism I'm just it's just wild we
didn't hear about that that was a 54
million
I didn't hear about being forced to wait
longer or pay more than white customers
that's insane how does how
thousands of people
the boy for them got it so I'm not
listening I'm just staunchly wanted to
uh that was that bad no you knew it was
something you knew it was something in
your menu you said they they had
something racist but ah who gives a
is what he said I'm defending their menu
and I thought I was very pretty similar
but I think Waffle House really shakes
it up a bit and I thought IHOP was gonna
was gonna um maybe take a dive because
they they had an identity crisis a
couple years ago where they switched to
a burger restaurant but then they
switched back and so you let them go the
way of the dodo bird you took Waffle
House I think a waffle house now in life
and you're just moderating correct yeah
I'm just giving like the uh but you're
not part of the battle well I'm saying
you're not picking aside for a loss or a
win no okay let's start the battle yeah
this is going to be the greatest match
you've ever been involved in I'm ready
type two
b-a-t-t-l-e budge all right so Sal is
moderating I am team Denny's Anthony's
team Waffle House
people love Waffle House you're right
they're Scrappy and in light of the
horrid and abundant racial accusations
that you're going to stand on the hill
to die for I now think there should be a
ship I think Waffle House is I was
originally I had the odds to make us
picking Denny's I think Denny's is still
going to take this I think Denny's
Denny's if you're watching and we know
that you are Denny's we have nothing
against you we're reading a report here
uh hopefully uh that's something that
was corrected move past and uh and
that's uh has nothing Denny's is I don't
know Danny as far as these types of
establishments go we'll call them
pancake houses okay as far as these
places go Denny's is the McDonald's of
these chains Denny's is and you know it
and I know I would say they beat Perkins
but I think IHOP is bigger than that I
think IHOP's much bigger than that well
if we were arguing IHOP then maybe that
would matter also to be fair Denny's
Denny's is
babe you're gonna hang your racist hat
on nothing but the Grand Slam breakfast
you're the one that just apologized to
them and are now confession in their
Acts
you can't hang everything on the Grand
Slam breakfast I'll say this about
Denny's a little racist no fights
racist
I'm just joking now but Denny's I I like
I mean look IHOP has always been around
right sure and Waffle House has grown
now Waffle House used to only be that
you can only find one
like in the southern region place now
they're they're way more prominent now
but to me why I say Denny's is the
McDonald Denny's as far back as I can
remember so I'm 46 I'll write that when
I was 8 17 is when I started you know
hanging out smoking a little pot
whatever it was
Denny's was the place like you had the
other options and who chose Denny's what
I have was accessible
it was never open late
guys hello fresh
I wonder if if our good are like Avid
listeners can
tell me about hellfresh because I say it
so much I feel like you guys have to be
using it by now and you have to have
your own experience and you have to know
all the Deets but I'm gonna do it again
hello fresh with them you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
you can skip trips to the grocery store
you count on hellofresh to make your
home cooking easy you make it fun you
make it affordable that's why it is
America's number one meal kit
um
they do all the shopping and meal
planning for you ingredients arrive at
your doorstep pre-portioned they're
ready to cook along with pictured
step-by-step recipe cards it's very very
easy even though the fall can feel
jam-packed hellofresh makes whipping up
home cooked dinner is actually doable
they have quick and easy options
including 15 minute meals I mean that's
less time than it takes to actually get
a delivery so come on with everything
pre-portioned delivered right to your
door it's a no-brainer uh take the
hassle out of meal time it's also 25
cheaper than grocery store shopping and
uh and takeout
uh
I never was cooking I've been using this
and I'm not a great cook but this is the
only way that I will cook when I have
everything laid out in front of me uh go
to hellofresh.com five zero taste buds
and use code five zero taste buds for
50. that's 5-0 50 off plus free shipping
that's
hellofresh.com50 taste buds and use code
50 taste buds for 50 off plus free
shipping come on hellofresh America's
number one meal kit it just wasn't the
place like Denny's the reason I saved
the McDonald's because McDonald's was
the other fast food like late night fast
food like you're going to get burgers
you want to go through a drive-through
it's you know it was it was always
McDonald's Denny's to me not to say that
there weren't any others I'm just saying
Denny's to me was that Denny's was like
the go-to like hey man it's it's 12 30
at night you want something we're gonna
go to Daddy why why isn't Waffle House
that wait where did you grow up Waffle
House very much was that and holy
did
there yeah oh
see your reaction oh see a reaction you
just jumped out of your chair to watch
something that happens at a Waffle House
I know we're talking about menus but you
sit at a Denny's you get a bunch of old
fogies sitting there with their little
coffees and you get Prime
entertainment as long as coupled with an
amazing breakfast whether it's in the
morning nice and interesting take the
food is a staple you're getting the food
yes but you have you have a chance at
big big time entities you go to a strip
club entertainers entertainers same
thing with Waffle House I will say this
about waffles I never eat at Waffle
House here's why let me establish why I
hate Waffle House so much I don't go in
there without Mason Waffle House and I'm
a big believer in fast food I I like
fast food I enjoy it Waffle House is the
only because it is sort of these are
sort of fast food places they're cousins
yeah Waffle House and I say this without
exaggeration it is one of the only
places I've ever eaten where the
stomachache
starts we should go out the crabs
you eat something bad and you go you
have the pain in your stomach and you
have to like three times in a row
I get that stomachache as I'm still
eating the food it's just so greasy it's
I'm like oh my God I feel terrible
immediately but if you're talking about
drunk but drunk or high you're gonna
want that grease I don't it's too much
even then I don't like it but here's the
thing the last time I ate at a waffle
house I went to years ago I was on the
road I got to I got into Georgia very
late
and it was literally the only thing that
was open and I went in and ate and it
was after this stuff started happening
with these videos the fights were coming
out and I got to tell you it did not
enhance the experience I was freaked out
when I was eating in there because I was
like it's some crazy fight gonna break
out because there were some people that
were a little off in there yeah yeah but
that's that's that's basically if you're
an adventurer you're going to want to
eat it the prices are unmatched I
remember looking at the first time I
went we were on the road like over a
decade ago and we went and they had the
laminated menu and she dropped it on a
table and I thought I was literally in
1984. yes I was like wait the whole meal
is 3.95 yeah so you can't beat that you
know what I mean I agree with that but I
will say I've I've had
I've had experiences in both okay in a
Denny's I've gone to a Denny's uh on the
road I met up with uh Roy wood Steve
Byrne and and and and and and and Q and
as we all went to a Denny's we were so
by the way shout outs to everybody in
that story but particularly Steve Byrne
Steve Byrne is real good for a let's go
get some oh yeah down and dirty food it
was after our show like he's really into
it all drunk yeah and we went to the
Denny's we were in uh is it was
Scottsdale it's a place in Arizona where
they use golf carts to get around right
now
Scottsdale Scottsdale yeah and uh we
went to the Denny's and we ordered we
sat down we were these people we said
we'll have one of everything
it was like 15 or 10 12 of us and we sat
around the table and they dropped him
and we ever the rule he took a bite and
passed took a bite and passed so I've
had some fun memories and then he caught
covet afterwards
I gotta tell you the silverware though
is is really like it's just a step above
plastic it's metal it is but it it's
metal but it's a thinned sheath of metal
that is
it just feels odd in the hand and this
this stains on them regardless of where
you are I will say when you're dealing
with metal silverware in a restaurant at
a Denny's level you're gonna have
spotted silver quite quite you're not
getting stainless I'm gonna be honest
with you you're probably not gonna get
very good silverware at Waffle House so
I think I think those cancel out
both these places by the way both of
these places have a I've been into both
of them enough they they all smell they
all have their own smell every day
smells the same every Waffle House
smells the same always all the time
which I don't know if that's a good
thing or a bad thing but it is
interesting about both places do you
feel like if if I was applying for a job
at a Waffle House that's a whole nother
level of excitement you know what I mean
like that's it's you're not just going
in you're not dipping a toe now you're
gonna work there like you're gonna be
there more than you as much as you are
home you're going to work full-time at a
Waffle House
you got to take a Krav Maga class or
something like that you have to like
make sure that you are prepared to to
defend your life and a good PPO I do
think there it also is kind of Club
energy there's good party moments in a
while okay right that's good that's a
good point that's a really good point
well let's see let's see that let's see
those I don't see those well I've lived
on tour with rappers and it's fun in the
waffle oh okay all right all right but
you're going in with you're going in
with like a a
um what do you call it uh well everyone
in there has their own Entourage an
Entourage right right okay so yeah
that's gonna be fun if you're going with
an Entourage yeah yeah I mean I mean at
this point Waffle House needs to put it
out a collection on like like almost
like the old like the bum fights or or
the best the best of backyard wrestling
you you I mean if I saw online like it's
like volumes one and two of the best
Waffle House Bros I would get that I
would buy it like that they're at that
level so take it but what it is they're
not putting on on airs you come you get
a waffle maybe you get threatened maybe
like like enter at your own risk work at
your own risk if you go to a Waffle
House or you work there you already know
your game on you are down to clown so
when you go to a Waffle House you're not
like oh my God a fight's breaking out
you're like oh my God a fight's breaking
out no and then you caught up in it dude
I don't know why you think you're just
gonna get to be a bystander man no
you're not gonna get caught up in it if
you open your mouth and talk to them
yeah yeah
you eat silently at the Waffle House the
only time you open your mouth is to
order the food you eat silently and you
wait for the action that is what you do
I would like to put I would like to put
menu against menu there's no contest
let's do it Denny's menu look at this
Denny look at the categories melts and
handhelds
right there pancakes and Crepes to be
fair daddies Denny's is covering every
shade of the spectrum of the food menu
well what but that but that's not that's
not a fair comparison because this is a
full-service Diner that serves other I'm
saying Waffle House correct me if I'm
wrong are they not just there there's
more than breakfast there's Burgers
there's steaks steak and eggs
at the waffles look Danny Waffle House
is mainly breakfast they got no it's all
breakfast breakfast sandwiches and melts
waffles hash browns it's all it's all
it's all breakfast there's got to be
steak and eggs biscuits
okay they have burgers and stuff
fair enough but you know what I like
about but they also hit pictures look
real that's also it doesn't look that
great that so it's you know but I but I
appreciate that like look at that slab
of me yeah like go backwards take a look
at that City ham right there okay
they could have put it on some they
busted out a plastic white plate and
they laid they didn't hire they didn't
hire a marketing firm okay the waffle
guy took out his phone they threw a
piece of
basically it's Canadian bacon on a plate
and they took that photo City ham
undoubtedly a dog whistle for dead cop
hahaha
what they got country ham they got two
cups
the country ham looks good I mean look
that looks really good come on they do
it on the food look it's a pork chop
right here and by golly man they just
threw that pork chop on a white plate
and took a photo it looks like it looks
like prop food this looks like fake food
no but it doesn't it doesn't I actually
give them props no no they're not
they're not trying to make it something
it's not it looks okay sandwiches let me
I don't mean it looks fake in the sense
of they they they they you know gassed
it up or whatever for the photos I mean
it looks fake like it looks like prop
food in the sense of like the hamburger
looks like a hamburger you know what I'm
saying yeah like it's just like
hamburger you know what I mean there's
nothing there's nothing else going on
like if a kid Drew one exactly that's
what I mean
um well let me bring this up because
this is one of my favorite things here
at Waffle House you can sit and watch
the cooks live and in front of you cook
everything huge Denny's these nasty ass
chefs they can put anything they want in
there if they don't like you they can
spit in the you can't see anything
what's going on at Denny's with an open
kitchen not open kitchen but with a
window where you can see the guys in the
kitchen
Waffle House is pulling a page out of
some of the Michelin star restaurants of
all time they are not Waffle House you
can only see the cooks who almost
because they can't afford walls
I think it's open concept kitchen and it
brings on its own feel I I okay I love
watching that's an interesting time
reminiscent of a Roadside Diner you go
in you pull over on Route 66 yes you sit
down and the guy the kid the guy in
front of you is griddling them up right
now it's very Road House it's very I I
don't disagree with that I don't
disagree with that but I will say this
Waffle House's specialty clearly is
breakfast that's the focus when we had
to click on more
to even get to the other stuff that
wasn't breakfast they are putting the
breakfast stuff front and center as the
focus
when it comes to breakfast
Denny's
the Grand Slam I mean this is the
breakfast meal across this is it but
that is the Big Mac Whopper Slurpee
whatever key thing you want to call it
of breakfast meals and chain restaurants
that is it dude I I get it but can I
just say this and I'm Devil's ad right
now I'm Devil's Advocate but
isn't that just they just named the
things that they put together so like
they didn't create anything with grand
slam it's like basically it's like two
eggs pancakes side of bacon toast and
you get all that and they call it the
grandson I will so you're like the Grand
Slam but you can go and order all those
things at Waffle House and not
Counterpoint to that though I'll let you
go first I'll just speak to your point
yeah I will say this
and I think that you will you might be
able to relate to this because you're as
old as I am the
dude don't you remember going to other
places
at a certain point in your life but
going do you have something like the
Grand Slam where it all comes together
and they go and they would go no you
have to get 12 eggs 12 pancakes and
you're like no put it all together I'll
do you one better I've said I'll have
the Grand Slam and they go this is not
Dennis
you want a little bit of everything yeah
like that's pretty pretty great pretty
great I'm sure I was gonna say they have
the grants excuse me they have yeah they
have the Grand Slam
um just going off what it's named The
Waffle House has what I order which is
the All-Star breakfast
Grand Slams anybody can hit them all
stars are at the top of their game every
single year and they hit multiple Grand
Slams a year and at a better price point
I think
the net is wider you're an All-Star of
what how many sports you narrated you
whittled it down
Grand Slam is a baseball reference but
but all that matters is is what the
people know and the people know the
Grand Slam nobody's going oh the
all-star
this is All-Star version of also Grant
Samurai's grand slammer version of
All-Stars let's let's just talk menu
name menu item names nobody is beating
Denny's Moon's over my Hammy the super
bird the grand slam the French slam
they're they're Danny started uh
1963. this is something we don't do a
lot uh nowadays we don't go back in and
look it was originally open as a coffee
shop under the name Danny's Donuts in
Lakewood California Denny's was known
for always being open and serving
breakfast lunch and dinner Denny's did
not close on holidays and nights except
we're required by law many restaurants
are located near freeway exits bars and
in service areas but 19. wait wait wait
let me stop on that point
let's let's tip our hat to the genius of
Denny's that they knew open these things
near Exit ramps so they see us as soon
as they get off I think the Waffle House
does it check this out though my friend
the very first Waffle House opened its
doors for the first time Labor Day
weekend
1955. in Georgia
eight years before the franchising of
Denny's now the site of the Waffle House
Museum the interior has been lovingly
recreated to capture the look and feel
of the original restaurant and uh it's
rooted in southern hospitality how do
you like that 2 000 of them spanning
wait what year did it first open oh 55.
oh wow so they're older than Denny's is
there a Denny's I don't know about that
but I will tell you this is there a
Waffle House Museum yeah oh did oh I
didn't even hear you say that yeah so
they're in 25 states only Waffle House
so that is going to be if Denny's is
Nationwide that's going to be tough I've
already seen a couple of the population
not not have been to a while but I've
already seen a couple people that said
on Twitter I don't even have a waffle
house where I live and I'm voting for it
okay so but yes you're right you're
right what are some of the people on the
phone say Danny thinks we should all go
to Waffle House with Denny's after this
for a bite I'm very hungry so
all I know is I'm sh Wait all I know is
that I sure don't feel that All-American
I am at a Waffle House Denny's where the
Wade staff looks like they don't wash
their hair and the flies go to
repopulate and die
you have to have at least two violent
felonies to eat
yeah when you go to Waffle House it's a
food and a show it's a modern day
medieval times that right there captures
exactly what you were trying to say
that's such a good line a modern day
Medieval Times that's crazy uh Waffle
House more like awful house never even
seen a Waffle House
Waffle House will take an ironic fight
vid clout vote
all right do you imagine a joust breaks
out in the water
that would be great
my mind
that's great the thing is it's a
possibility
it is
Waffle House has been there for me more
than my therapist ever has
see that's where I think you're going to
get some real points I feel like well I
feel like Denny's could take the lead
and the win in the sense that
it's known it's out there it's kind of
like this thing that's just sort of been
in your life since childhood for a lot
of people and one capacity or another
Waffle House as you get older
for a lot of people becomes a lifestyle
staple
where it's like no man once a week I go
to the Waffle House at this time after I
do this thing because that's my spot you
know what I mean like I do have the arm
sleeve
I'm saying it as a pro for Waffle House
oh okay okay I'm saying that's what will
that's what will be the biggest to me
Joe Rosa looks like a Denny
I got an STD from reading this to me
well it depends night after drinking or
after working third shift in Waffle
House sometimes you need greasy food but
Denny's is pretty decent food if you
don't need crave one unable to hand the
greasy food you know that's a good point
too Waffle House is a little more in the
zone of
you know it's a niche thing it's like
when you're in this certain way that's
gonna be the thing Denny's is a little
more across the board maybe not as
exciting but I don't get the job done
you know I have a question are the
waffles good at Waffle House yeah
they're pretty good like are they like
like obviously it's in the name so is it
do they specialize in the waffle
you don't have to but I know you don't
have to I don't know I don't get away
with not having one but I think they're
pretty good don't they have like a
special formula that's what I mean I
think essentially they're known the
thing they're really known for like when
they sell them back that I would eat
there that wouldn't make me want to
myself but yeah but uh the one thing
that I feel like they're really known
for first of all they have grits which
is hard to find in a chain secondly the
hash browns the like loaded
whatever the hell it's called they like
have different ways of preparing the
hash browns and like there's like a
version of the hashbrowns I think that
have like cheese oh okay bacon and all
this stuff and like that to me like when
people say how much they love Waffle
House they always mention that to me is
like oh but the hash browns like fully
loaded or whatever it is you know so go
I'm just saying you seem to be siding
now with Waffle House I don't hear many
positives other than just you know it's
a little nostalgic nostalgic you know I
think Denny's I think Denny's I'm not
starting with honestly I really mean it
I eat I get a stomach ache immediately
the the I don't like anything that they
really do
outside of maybe the waffle is fine
who's got better bathrooms
Denny's Denny's
oh but but here's the thing Denny's you
know it's not like I'm driving on a on a
road trip and I light up if I see a
Denny's but if I'm driving on a road
trip and I need to stop and eat and I
stop and eat at a Denny's I'm not mad at
it like I'm like Denny's can get the job
done any time of day breakfast lunch
dinner late night they can service you
with something that's pretty damn good
you know and like Denny's does have
stuff then I would go as far as to say
like oh I really enjoy that uh Waffle
House to me is very
I'm seeing a lot of well when you're
drunk there's nothing beats Waffle House
and it's like okay so for some people
that'll that'll that's what would take
the win for Waffle House sure is the
neatness of that
but for me what makes Denny's better is
it's just so serviceable in so many ways
you know I'll give you the benefit of
the doubt only because I do like one I
like one of their desserts it's the
Apple if you could pull up the menu I
think it's apple crisp no no at Denny's
okay the apple pie something it's so
good that I will doordash it and accept
the ice cream being slightly melted wow
really yes okay so we're that's also one
of Dante's favorite uh
oven baked caramel apple pie crust Yes
Yes sounds good that is like the
official dessert of the LA The Lads by
the way is myself hook Dante Martin his
brother Darius and uh action Andretti no
way end of the night if Denny's is open
we're getting a whole as a faction
I'm not kidding I had a band in high
school called Fancy Labs oh really your
crew is called The Lads yeah we're all
the lads I'll say but but here's the
other thing too
um with uh oh Denny's milkshakes man
Denny's makes mean milkshakes they're
really good are they data blueberry
milkshake when I was in college it was
insane I'll tell you one thing I just
remembered about about Waffle House um
in the show you got punished one time
and he was gonna go to a kindergarten
and read a children's book to them and
we got to write the children's book He
didn't know anything about it and so we
wrote this book his name's you know Q
his name is uh his name was Q the dung
beetle so we made him a dung beetle
right that's who the character was and
in the book which we wrote and
Illustrated he was just completely down
and out on his luck he was drinking his
wife left him and when he was at his
most despondent Rock Bottom moment
Turn the Page and he is uh preposition
preposition prepositioning a uh
propositioning a prostitute in the
parking lot
and we had to call it waffle home
because you couldn't get in trouble
all it says is how much
it's a waffle home and he's in the
parking lot and there's a surly looking
woman there and it just says how much
and he read this to children
that's so funny so uh yeah take that as
I mean as a plus or a minus right I
don't know oh all right yeah let's we
did the phones let's do we we we're
gonna we're gonna go to Humble Pie it's
called where we picked the winner look
at that we reveal the winner but plug
anything you want to plug first
before we do that uh make sure you like
when does this come out this one will be
from a week for Monday
a week from well two weeks from General
check out aew Dynamite aew Rampage aew
Collision Dynamite is Wednesday nights
at 8pm on TBS Friday night aw Rampage 10
p.m TNT and then our brand new show
which is aew Collision Saturday night 8
PM TNT you can catch myself the
acclaimed daddy ass scissoring all night
long in the you know with the trios
Champion so we're just gonna keep
winning baby uh check that out and also
make sure you follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at bones underscore official I
just started a tick tock which is
Bowen's underscore official 37. I love
it dude thank you for being here man it
was so nice meeting you and hanging out
this was really fun I had a lot of fun
congratulations on everything man thank
you it's amazing wrestling's wrestling
is you can't as much wrestling as you
want you can consume right now and I
watch all of it so I'm gonna start back
in I'm gonna start back in please are
you what are you doing Wednesday
this was well I fly to Toronto on
Thursday so maybe nothing you and I are
going too but you're going to a show cue
me Jay and uh far we're going to uh
Forest Hill Arthur Ashe to watch the
dynamite I mean do you have do you have
room for one more yeah I could I could
the person we deal with though all right
let me see what's up maybe I'll come
yeah okay so when we have when we stop
I'll hit him up and see if they can get
a throw okay
um thank you for being here so how this
works is pimp reveals the winner whoever
wins has to say to the loser I still
love you the loser says I love you too
that's it okay here we go purple pie
what do we got
Waffle House wins for those listening
53.2 to 46.8 which is a close battle but
loss just said it's only in 25
States that's wild that's I mean Waffle
House
either that speaks to either of these
strengths of the waffle house fans or
the hatred
[Laughter]
before we leave I gotta end it with this
I'd like to ask both of you to throw up
your scissors yeah
me Daddy
and I'd like to throw up mine too and
end this the only way I know how by
saying scissors
scissor tastes
that's way better than ours
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them